here's a deacon what guests had to say
after the show we're back now hey Doc
you snuck up behind me there okay uh max
do you think there are similarities
between America's treatment of Obama and
its treatment of the Harlem Hellfighters
after they returned home from fighting
World War well he says two but one is
the war oh no of course I mean it's it's
a tremendous backlash whenever we take
two or three steps forward as a country
there's always going to be a step back
that's why we call them reactionaries
because they react and you know because
of political correctness they're not
allowed to speak their minds now they
have to call him a Kenyan or they have
to use some other word but when you see
bumper stickers that say an African lion
in the zoo and a lion African in the
White House it's pretty clear there's a
back oh yeah what did Ted Nugent call
them in human Mongol and then men is
offended when you think that the way you
call him a racist when even where you
get it would even started at the Sarah
Palin rally people were there monkey
dolls yeah and if people pretty explicit
and I think really the worst word is
mongrel that he used not subhuman
because wrong girl implies race-mixing
if that's the real crime against the
racist is black man white I mean there
is a word that sticks in their throat
and that's the n-word they want to say
it so bad yeah remember in the 60s they
used to say [ __ ] that was a word they
invented yeah they were so anxious and
desperate just and they couldn't
publicly so they kind of just yeah
changed won the [ __ ] yeah and it would
be in the context of I think was
Eastland the senator who used exactly
that language saying you know the Negro
wants to be on his own that he likes
segregation it's what he prefers he's
happier that way it would all be mixed
into sort of trying to say that they're
sort of weird social conscious what you
understood back then like when George
Wallace said segregation now segregation
always okay we get it here's who you are
it's when people who are clearly against
Obama said oh no no it's it's not not
about race at all no he's just a
socialist African Kenyan line white
you're talking about the fringe fringe
fringe of the point zero one percent and
that's defending the indefensible nobody
agrees well unfortunately when she went
Ted when Ted Nugent said what he said
only that
where the case yep it's I've said is
it's not Ted Nugent it's the people that
still rallied around him
it's the same people make about Muslims
why is the majority not speaking up
against the minority that is doing visa
most extreme the most extreme thing when
Ted Nugent says something like that why
isn't the Republican Party but waited
all that when clive in bundy home races
yeah that's when Clive in Bundy went
berserk and started going racist for I
always thought the guy was a kook even
before you know like Sean Hannity went
down there and interviewed him I thought
the guy was a kook and then he went
berserk and every conservative pretty
much was like this guy's nuts
what do you say about people who are not
terrorists themselves and I'm talking
about muslims or clive in bundy but have
the same agenda or believe in the same
things or are very sympathetic to things
that terrorists do because i think
anytime you use violence especially in
to defend your religion you are a
terrorist I mean there were millions of
Muslims who are willing to kill Salman
Rushdie if they saw him on the street in
a second in a heartbeat
doesn't that make you a terrorist in
your heart isn't clive in bundy a
terrorist even though he didn't do the
things that those are not is all the
crime we're not going to go up first of
all no but there is connecting tissue
between the two is there not yes I'd
give you that yes that is going to issue
it well there's a there are also plenty
yes there are but there are also plenty
of people who who do speak up against
this kind of extremism but don't get the
attention they deserve don't get the
kind of the because they're saying
things that are that make perfect sense
in their poker
don't make news dr. Blaser is there any
link between the over you are this a
great quest the overuse of antibiotics
and the autism epidemic because that's a
hotly debated issue so we know that the
bacteria our body are helping program
how the brain develops and a third of
the babies born in the United States
today are born by c-section they don't
have the normal round founder at
one-third and in some countries it's one
you have in many reasons but it's just
it's like antibiotics it's crept up and
up and up something that's good is
overused in Scandinavia it's only 12 or
15 percent in Brasil and Equador
it's almost 50
and here we've gone from 18 percent to
32 so it's gone up so the bacteria
aren't normal and now the average child
in the United States before they're 2
they've had three courses of antibiotics
and these have collateral effects so I
don't know whether autism is due to this
but it's plausible and needs to be
tested I can tell you're just having
kids a trip to the pediatrician almost
always ends with an antibiotic you know
and you're so overused at a certain
point they have to step up to the next
one because the first course of
antibiotic no longer works on a little
kid whose immune systems are still
developing I think it is very much and
there's a lot of very very ation in how
doctors use antibiotics there's they're
using and about 50% more in the south
than in the West why culture and
practice what's the culture with is it
like the fried
in marketing my antibiotics that's right
doctor of chicken for sure correct isn't
it marketing too because I remember just
even in the doctor's offices the company
that makes amoxicillin has a big
Blackard as soon as you walk in there's
lying free samples I mean very much like
free lunches yeah it's okay all right
well I hope we did some good tonight
educating people and I hope they won't
take it as much or is Dick Cheney really
this is where you Andy your personal
hero when it comes to Iraq uh I think
Dick Cheney's a great man and I think
he's very I think he's I think he's very
misunderstood I mean okay so handy I
yeah
fundamentally disagree this is a guy
though he doesn't care what other people
think and after September 11 room right
I'll give him that right he has no
pollsters all right look after September
11 2001 GW Bush and Dick Cheney had a
very serious job and that was to make
sure the country did not get attacked
again and they that was their if like it
did under their watch look I mean like
when they were predominant and festered
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna look I'm not
gonna blame Bush for bin Laden I'm not
gonna blame Clinton I will he was a
terrorist that festered we understand
Bush had a memo entitled Osama bin Laden
is standing right behind you
look when Clinton hat Clinton had a
chance to take out your zama bin Laden
in Jalalabad and Ryan do it right but
can I just add just make one issue what
you said after 9/11 george w bush had a
constitutional responsibility to the
country safe the vice president has no
constitutional authority and his bride
should nation' dying but he should not
have been running that White House he
should not have had the power the
unelected
unconstitutional power he had over
george w bush all right
from the sublime to the ridiculous max
Brooks will you please settle a bet are
you named after Maxwell Smart well I
know why they're asking it because your
father wrote the great you know get more
get smart no I'm named after Maximilian
a subject of the Kaiser and my
grandfather if yeah subject of the
subject of the Kaiser said it right
there on his passport German Jew very
proud yes when German were Jewish what
could possibly go wrong okay uh Bobby
are the ethics of journalism changing
hmm no they're not people who are
practicing them sometimes don't apply
them as much the ethics are the same as
they always were what are what are those
ethics report the truth provide context
when when you can and give all sides of
the of a point of give all sides of a
story that if you can possibly do it of
course you know very simple problem at
the question I got is that you say
journalism or media and people think of
different things I mean Entertainment
Tonight is media yeah and Dexter Filkins
is media and you know there's this big
array in between some guy blogging
online is also claiming to be a
journalist and right and often is not
and their ethics they don't necessarily
follow all the ethics that we're
required to do here though veloute telly
honestly thank you very much everybody
real time
ask villainous guests or questions right
after the show at hbo.com or on Twitter